oh
well
thank you thank you all
hey will when are we going to get you to
come out of your shell
you've got to get over this shyness i'm
really happy doing your show
thank you very much looks like we're
great we're very glad to have you
because this is like the first time you
know
it's sort of like you know like a you
know a first date kind of
you know so just respect me you know
just respect me
i will try very hard respect me in the
morning we have a chaperone
unfortunately
it's not going to get out of hand how
are you doing man i'm fine how are you
doing good you look great
thank you thank you
this is showbiz talk you look terrific
so what's up that was a good clip
yeah you're an action hero now
schwarzenegger schwarzenegger
willie schwarzenegger that's your
new name yes absolutely you know i was
in great shape for that movie too you
got to check it out april 7th y'all
comes out april 7th bad boys
yeah you're wet you got into shape for
this oh yeah you know i worked out
you know and i bumped up and everything
you know yeah
it's a scene where you know my shirt is
open and i'm running you know in slow
motion
yeah they couldn't afford to slow it
down with the cameras right
[Laughter]
why do you cross your eyes in slow
motion because that's some that's like a
slo-mo feature
you know you yeah i didn't know my name
slow motion
that sounds like a good movie though
it's a great movie it's a great movie
you know
when you see will and martin you're
going to get the comedy you expect the
comedy you expect the comedy
but there's more
really yeah there's action
there's action there's adventure and
drama
you know so it's an all around you know
there's a there's a dance sequence
there's a dance sequence yes
you know i do a split we're all looking
forward no it's you know what it's like
it's really it's really
different you know because you know it's
like a
serious action movie you know that's
what that was a shock for people you
know everybody oh willie martin they're
going to be on the acting stupid you
know
and we couldn't pull them off dumb
anyway you know they're going
to be stupid in the movie you know but
when you actually see the picture put
together
you know there's action there's
explosions and all of that you know
you know i'm buffed you know in the
movie that's all right i got that
message yeah you know because
you know you did that yeah yeah you said
that because i say that a lot
you know because you know i'm really
sick because i'm flabby and nasty now
you know as soon as the movie was over
you just it was the moment
it was over right the taco bell fast you
know
you're not calling on the way you know
give me on seven tacos
and a burrito extra fat you know because
because i do you know i really can get
them with extra fat extra fat yeah
that's important you know that's how you
make them really taste good
am i talking about you know because i
talk a lot you know so now you're here
you're doing a great i just wanted to
mention one thing i i mentioned these
two out in the hall but i wanted to say
it on the air i
thought i didn't i'm a big freak yeah
yeah i'm a big fan i was shocked you
know i wasn't going to say freak you
know
but you know because you're a kind man
yeah you know you hit it on the head
though
thank you well
it's the night you know we can use that
word and friend in friendship you're
really taller i would say probably will
you
and i'm buff too
he's gotta agree with his show yeah yeah
sure you really work out
yeah like sly you know yeah you don't
want to mess with me
yeah no but you know i was really
surprised about it were you like six
four yeah you play ball
yeah i i played a lot more ball when i
oh no i'm sorry
i'm a i am a very good highlight player
i want to make that clear right now what
kind of ball were you talking about
uh no i i used to actually all right
hold on let me just see i cause i come
out excited i'm gonna let you ask me a
question
when i was just gonna make a comment i
thought
this is this is your you're going to
take a question
like you know it's like all right he got
asked me i wasn't going to ask you if i
was going to compliment you
that's very nice no i'm sorry
no i was going to compliment you on uh
six degrees of separation i thought you
were great in that movie i really did
i thought you were very good
you know it's just a it's a hard thing
to do you had the tv thing going but you
stepped in there
with you know donald sutherland and you
did a great job
you know actually that that was like the
most difficult thing i've ever had to do
in entertainment i worked for six months
you know working out and a dialect coach
and working on the script and all that
and that was you know that was like the
serious intellectual beat down
you know just after afternoon
this is the end of the day you work in
uh you know
distracted you know that's all i could
see because i
i wasn't buffed you know that's the
important thing you need to be buffed
for a movie to be successful oh okay so
now you got it together
i got it together all right that is you
know just you know
i'm really happy to be here i'm sorry
i'm taking i'm sorry no you're doing
fine
you have this incredible rap career
going you had a rap career
and then you put it it's on the back
burner now right well you know what what
happened really was
with the music is is like a baby you
know
what the hell are you talking about he's
about to be deep this is going to be
oh deep okay i'll put my deep face on
whoa see that's a good deep face thank
you because you make me feel profound
when you do that
tell me all of that no but see like
music
[Applause]
wait that's my i have a crush on you
facebook yeah what the hell am i doing i
was like hey
that don't look like a deep
all right all right let's see like music
you have to devote your life to it you
know
music like whereas with the television
show you know i can go
play some golf for a couple hours and i
come back and the script is done no no i
don't like that i don't like that then
go play some more golf and come back
you know you have writers but with the
music i have to do it all myself
it's a full-time film it's a full-time
thing you can't really half do it so you
know that's kind of why
i've put it slightly on the back burner
i'm you know i'm waiting for the
inspiration
i'm waiting for the passion to come
pouring from me
to make more music oh yeah
yeah that was my face that looked
scary yeah that's deep you know all
right that's a very deep
yeah but i would also think you would i
would think you would miss the touring i
would think that'd be come on do you
miss that at all or is that too much of
a grind
yeah well tour you know what touring was
like you know at 17 and 18 years old
touring can be fun you know you go out
and you're in different cities and you
acting wild but
you know i used to get in trouble and i
can't afford that right now
what kind of trouble are we talking here
uh you know
do we need to go into the trouble you
want to go into the trouble no no
you know come on
just a little will smith acting up on
the road what are we talking about there
was this one time see what happens you
go into those small towns and all that
you know and and the women gonna love
you you know cause you you go on stage
[Applause]
all right
so you're going to you go on tour right
and the women you know the women are
screaming you know right
right can we touch you you know all that
stuff right so you know what i'm
supposed to do you know the women want
to touch me you know
you know it's tough it's tough yeah so
the guys tend to get
a little upset about that you know so we
were in uh
macon georgia one night and and what
what yeah yeah
we shouldn't have been there the first
thing we were gonna we was in macon
georgia and you know
we i'm out on the balcony the hotel all
the girls are screaming so the guys are
down
you know on the street level and you
know hey man
why you up here they call out women man
you know they ain't funny you ain't cool
you ain't all that right so you know
i mean i can't have somebody screaming
at me calling me names and stuff so you
know i mooned them you know
you know i'll move them you know it
sounds like you had to you had no choice
so i'm up on the balcony of the hotel
you know
and i'm mooning them right yeah and then
all of a sudden a light flash on my ass
and the cop said freeze
oh don't move and then
okay gotta pull my pants up man a little
chilly out here you know yeah
then you then your butt is in a lineup
absolutely you know
is that the ass that moved you
i think it was that one right there man
so yeah you know instead of getting a
little trouble on tour so i'm saying
i'm a little more mature now yeah things
are better now
on full moon nobody you know don't leave
yourself you're not getting a little
chick you know
you can get it back up quick you know i
know what you're saying i know what
you're saying the mooning techniques
you know it's different i understand
if it's cool you know you know you give
them a little mac tonight you know
everything right
that is not the nickname for it
mcdonald's people will not be happy
uh now listen we are i think we are
flush out of time but i just wanted to
mention i know uh you you began you
started working with your dad your dad's
uh yeah
repairman is that right refrigeration
repair man electrician yeah i know you
started out with him is he actually here
is that
oh my dad's here yeah the first kid
and this was a record i asked them not
to wear that shirt but that's what they
did
well i happen to like that shirt you
were just showing your butt to america
and you're giving him a hard time